thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
alexander grieschuk after a
scintillating victory
against lupulescu with the white pieces
uh alexander first of all
congratulations you're now the co-leader
how does that feel thank you yeah as i
said it's all this leadership is
illusion but uh yeah the game
was i played the rare move b3
okay h5h4 is automatic were you
surprised by his opening choice
it felt a bit provocative let's see no
he plays
three openings french this one
and karokan but karo khan he almost gave
up
and french i was not sure if he would
play because he
played the exact same line i prepared
for candidates so
i figured it's far from certain he's
going to
play it again and yes this one
i just wasn't sure what he's going to
play
and yes this b3 this is already a very
critical position there are two normal
moves for black
but okay king e7 is at least can be
understood but another one is r7 which
is like the best move according to
computer okay so you were still within
your preparation at this point yeah but
because this is like a tub here
i mean this position it's like this
bishop d3 and it's like until move 40
some series so
and b3 is a fresh move sort of and
bishop b5 yeah
i actually was not sure what's
wrong with it but i was i knew there is
yeah it's wrong
and i think i found a nice move queen
one
the point is i want rook d5 and
if he plays rook c8 now i take and play
queen e2 because now i lured
this one through down yeah so
yeah so okay and here uh
it started to play everything very bad
cleaning two is a very ugly move
even if like by computer it's okay but i
should play something like king a2 or
uh and to instead like look at this
position and
look then that this
like my king now is on a1 just one check
away from getting mated
his rook is active my queen is passive
instead his king is now
safe instead of being in meeting that so
okay maybe it's still
winning for me but and then rook g4 here
allowed c5
and yeah and now i win
because the rook civ 8 rook c3 are also
now straightening cds 6 and then d7
series the check
so yeah but i was not happy
that's how i converted you've uh offered
incredible pressure against uh the uh
two underdogs of the tournament with the
white pieces was that the strategy all
along going into
the tournament once you found out the
pairings no
but i mean
with constantine um he plays a bit
w's openings against e4 so
of course i was going to play e4 and
against bogdan
okay i just got lucky he was extremely
close to drop
basically one move away luck is a big
word
uh how do you feel about your chances to
clinch the title here in bucharest
no as i said i don't have
too much optimism with such play
so okay let's just see
absolutely optimism no optimism you're
still the leader congratulations sasha
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few days no i think optimism is
better than pessimism
but unfounded optimism is the worst
out of three we're definitely not going
to see any of that guys
back to you in the studio thank you
christian and let's take a look